your character negan started out as one
of the most hateful characters I've ever
seen on any television show and I'm a
big Walking Dead fan and I've gotten to
know a couple of the cast members and
then had to watch you brutally murder
some of them with your baseball bat and
I was just i remembered actually having
real true hatred for your character and
you yeah it's very blurry I'll be a
blurry line but I'm just curious now
what what they've managed to do is have
your character evolve and they've
they've managed to keep you in the game
all this time and I'm just curious what
do you think people can look forward to
and obviously not giving anything away
but some evolution has happened over
time yeah I think yes the introduction
to my character was rough really rough
yeah yeah yeah and I totally understand
and appreciate the the hatred that I
still get and then and then I spent the
last year in showed years I think it was
like it's been a time jump so it was
like seven years I think approximately
negan's been in the slammer and among
other things he formed a relationship
with the youngest Grimes
Judith Grimes who we now see is like an
11 year old girl and so you've seen a
different side of negan everybody wants
to talk about being like this Redemption
arc I I don't know that there's a lot of
redemption to be had for a guy like
negan i we know that in his before the
pre apocalypse life that he had he was a
teacher he worked with kids I I think he
hasn't a certain affinity toward toward
kids anyway and and he really likes
Judith and I think seeing that side of
him has done a lot for his reputation
with fans maybe they don't want to kill
me as much as they used to right that
being said I think what we can look
forward to this year is out of jail for
one right negan's out of jail and
re-entering which way is he going to go
which way is he gonna go and it's I have
been having so much fun this year
because now that we have seen different
sides to him we know the the dark side
the the really kind of rough leader and
and what he is capable of and then we
saw him interacting with Judith and you
see a another side to him and and we saw
him want to die and kind of beg Maggie
to end his life that was all truthful he
was that was that wasn't you know negan
trying to put on a show and so if you
put all that together and then you've
come out of it at the end that this year
you start to see this other side to him
but the great thing is we're gonna get
kind of negan back yeah you know full
full yeah it's that they used to say
about Nixon let Nixon be next and let
negan be negan better clapper from The
Walking Dead and and this is you are in
prison but your time there is coming to
an end so yeah let's take a look movie
surprise you knocked off work early I
thought you couldn't get enough for the
great outdoors it's starting listen if
you've got something to say can you just
please get to the point because I don't
have time today it's seriously oh boy
why don't you just Nestle him below me
and let me baby bird a little bit of my
wisdom into that pretty little mouth of
yours
you see people tend to get mixed up on
about who they hate yesterday I was
public enemy number one
no well now I'm the guy that picks the
vegetables takes out the trash I'm okay
with that for now at least but until
this whole thing passes I want to keep
my head down so people don't move me
from the proverbial semi us category to
the category of them that's not what's
happening here
I didn't say is I said that it will you
see the bogeyman just stuck his gnarly
skin
word masks out from behind that closet
door and people are putting their
and pants back on
[Applause]